definition doesn't say anything about uniqueness and in fact there's a very interesting relationship among different purifications of the same state but
we'll discuss that a little bit later in the lesson next we'll consider Schmid DEC compositions which are expressions of
bipartite quantum State vectors in a certain form that I'll describe momentarily they're named after aard
Schmidt the same Schmid known for the Graham Schmid orthogonalization procedure but in the case of Schmid decompositions they probably shouldn't
be named after Schmidt it's actually mathematically equivalent to something called the singular value decomposition for matrices which is something that was
actually rediscovered multiple times but that does happen sometimes but anyway here's what we mean
when we refer to a Schmid decomposition for an arbitrary choice of a Quantum State Vector s for a pair of
systems XY it's always possible to write s in a special form that form is as we
have here on the screen where R is some positive integer p 0 through p r minus one are positive real numbers that
together form a probability Vector x0 through XR minus1 are unit vectors corresponding to the system X and y0
through y rus1 are unit vectors corresponding to the system y now that might not look particularly
special until I tell you that both of the sets x0 through XR minus one and y0 through y Rus one must be
orthonormal so why is that special well if we were to pick any basis for one of the two bases let's say
the X vectors which correspond to the system X then we could always express s in this form and that would force us to
select the Y vectors in a particular way in fact we do this pretty routinely like we do with a standard basis when we're
setting ourselves up to analyze a standard basis measurement but in general even if we choose an orthonormal basis for the X
vectors the Y vectors we get aren't necessarily going to be orthonormal similarly if you picked an
orthonormal basis for the Y vectors and you tried to express s in form again you could but again the X vectors wouldn't
necessarily be orthonormal and finally if you did pick orthonormal vectors for both systems and
you tried to express s in a form like this it wouldn't necessarily work because you might find yourself in need of some cross terms but there's only one
index in this sum which is a so the form is special but it is always possible to
write a given unit Vector s like this and here's how you can do it first compute a spectral decomposition
for the reduced state of either of the two systems it doesn't matter which but for the sake of describing how this is done let's look at the reduced state of
X so we're tracing out y so that means that p 0 through p r minus one are igen
values of this reduced State row and x0 through XR minus one are unit IG vectors corresponding to these IG values and by
the way the understanding here is that we're ignoring the terms for which which the IG values are zero because those terms don't contribute anything to the
sum and that is to say that p 0 through p r minus one are all positive real numbers and R is the number of non-zero
igen values counting multiplicities which is equal to the rank of row so that gives us p 0 through p r
minus one as well as x0 through XR minus one and all that's left is to find the vectors y0 through y Rus
one there's only one choice that can possibly work those vectors are uniquely determined at this point and they can
easily be found using the simple formula that's shown on the screen and what's amazing here is that
if we Define these vectors in this way then they are guaranteed to be orthonormal and that gives us a Schmid decomposition I won't argue that in this
video but it isn't too difficult and you can consult the written material for the lesson in case you're interested check
the video description for a link as usual as an example let's consider this
Quantum State Vector which we obtained as a purification of the density Matrix example that we keep coming back
to it isn't a Schmid decomposition because the zero and the plus States aren't orthonormal but we can find one
using the procedure that I just described the first step is to compute a spectral decomposition for the redu
state of X which is that same example of a density Matrix and here's a spectral decomposition I of it which we saw back
in lesson 9 so we choose p 0 P1 x0 and X1 as is
shown on the screen p 0 and P1 are the igen values of row and x0 and X1 are
corresponding unit igen vectors and so it remains to compute y0 and y1 and if we do this we get cat Plus
for y0 and -1 * Kat minus for y1 that's not immediate you have to
actually do the calculation to see it but that is what we get and as expected those two vectors are orthonormal as
they will always be if you've done the calculations correctly and that gives us a Schmid DEC
composition Schmid decompositions are very handy in many situations and shortly we'll see what they tell us
about purifications purifications aren't unique a given Quantum State represented
by a density Ma will in fact have infinitely many purifications there is however a close
relationship that always holds between any two purifications of the same state and it's sometimes called the unitary
equivalence of purifications here's how it works let row be a density Matrix
representing a Quantum state of a system X and suppose that we have any two purifications of that state that are
pure states of the same compound system so so for the sake of concreteness let's suppose that s and fi
are quantum State vectors of a pair of systems XY that both give us row when the system Y is traced
out what the unitary equivalence of purification says is that there must be a unitary operation U that acts only on
the system y that transforms SII into fi in other words although these are
arbitrary purifications of row and we don't assume anything about them except that they both purify row and they're
both states of the same compound system XY they have to be equivalent in some sense up to a unitary operation on y
alone we'll see a few examples that illustrate why this is interesting and what implications it has but first let's
see why it's true let's begin with a spectral decomposition of row which is the
density Matrix that both SII and fi purify and just like we did when we discussed the Schmid decomposition we're
going to assume that we've thrown away all of the terms corresponding to zero igen values so p 0 through p r minus1
are all positive real numbers x0 through XR minus one are orthonormal igen vectors of row and R happens to be the